Speaker 1: I was assuming we would start today's
show by talking about the new Republican speaker
of the House of Representatives, because, after
all, Republicans took over, even though it was by
a small margin, the control of the House based on
their wins in the 2022 midterm election November
8th. And it was time yesterday for them to
select a new speaker of the House. But no,
they have not done it. And Republicans are in the
midst of what is one of the biggest humiliating,
self-inflicted embarrassments in recent American
political history. Republicans have suffered a
true humiliation, failing to elect a speaker of
the House after three rounds of voting. The House
ultimately adjourning yesterday without speaker,
and they will start again today and they're
likely already going right now as you listen to
today's program. Most Republicans voting for Kevin
McCarthy, but not all. There is a faction that
has opted not to support Kevin McCarthy and this
actually led to Hakeem Jeffries on the Democratic
side, with Democrats united behind Jeffries
actually coming closer to the 218 votes that are
needed than McCarthy in some of the votes. CNBC
has a good, nice, concise article about it by
Christina Wilkie. The House of Representatives
adjourned for the day Tuesday without a speaker
after Republican leader Kevin McCarthy failed
three consecutive votes to secure enough support
to be selected to the post. This is a historic
situation. It's an historic situation. Some are
even saying it's the first time in 100 years
that the majority party failed to coalesce around
a candidate to speaker in this number of votes.
And we don't know what the step is. The next step
is at this point in time. We will get to that.
After the first ballot resulted in votes for
several Republicans. The next two rounds saw
McCarthy's opponents coalesce around a new
contender, Congressman Jim Jordan of Ohio,
a longtime McCarthy ally. Jim Jordan says he
doesn't want it. And Lauren, Bob Baer and Scott
Perry are saying Jim Jordan is sort of like George
Washington. George Washington didn't want to be
president, but he did it. And they are talking
about Jim Jordan in the same delusional terms,
which we will get to a little bit later. What
does this mean for the long term of the Republican
Party's ability to. I was going to say govern.
But it's like they don't really plan to govern the
government. They plan to investigate Hunter Biden,
which we will also get to a little bit later. But
this is embarrassing. And Tucker Carlson is
saying it's becoming a joke. Sean HANNITY is
saying that it is becoming a joke and we don't
exactly know the direction this will ultimately
go. The CNBC article also pointed out during each
of the three voice votes, every Democrat rallied
unanimously around incoming minority leader
Hakeem Jeffries, a former guest on this program,
by the way. But a sect of conservative Republicans
split from their party to back other candidates,
including Jim Jordan, as I mentioned, in an
unexpected twist. McCarthy lost support as
the voting continued, which is just hilarious to
see when in the third round, Florida Republican
Congressman Byron Donalds announced his support
for Jordan after voting twice for McCarthy
as a result of Donald's defection, McCarthy got
202 of the 218 votes needed. Jeffries got to 12,
getting quite close, in fact. Now, is it likely
that Hakeem Jeffries is going to be the speaker
of the House of Representatives? It is not likely.
And there are headlines saying, could Democrats
end up with the speakership? I don't believe that
it is likely. I believe a more likely scenario is
if Republicans don't move to someone else, that
some Democrats end up joining the majority of
Republicans. But AOC is saying that's not going
to happen and that Democrats are going to remain
united. So I think the least likely scenario is
Hakeem Jeffries becomes the speaker of the House,
but it's not a zero chance. And man, that would be
unbelievable. So that's what happened yesterday. I
have no news for you about the next speaker of the
House. Maybe we will later today. But of course,
everyone on the Republican side weighing
in about this. One of those people,
the failed former president Donald Trump. Let's
talk about that because it's quite interesting.